it follows is a movie that I've heard
about for quite some time it's been one
of my most anticipated movies of the
year if you watched my most anticipated
movies of 2015 video you would have seen
this movie as one of the first ones I
talked about in that video and I have
received literally hundreds of tweets
and Facebook messages and emails on
YouTube comments Chris when are you
going to see this movie
guys it finally opened literally tonight
actually it opens tomorrow I went to the
late-night showing tonight so I can see
it as soon as possible
it follows is a new horror film that's
told in an 80s retro way complete with
an old-fashioned John Carpenter 80s
electronic score shots of suburbia that
look lifted right out of Halloween and
that's not necessarily a bad thing now
essentially what this movies about I'm
not going to give too much away is a
sexually transmitted disease of sorts
that can be passed along to people and
then this thing whatever it is seems to
be following them everywhere and once
you get it you're basically now
if you guys watch my problem with horror
movies today video you would have seen
me rag on the endless Hollywood cliches
in horror nowadays with movies like
Annabelle and Ouija making lots of money
despite how terrible they are I praise
the babadook in that video a horror
movie that took a look at depression and
grief and told it in a monster movie way
and it was fantastic and it terrified me
I love that movie but not everyone likes
that movie it's a movie that general
audiences are not going to appreciate
because they just want the same thing
over and over again and those audience
members are going to hate it follows
because it follows is very much like
that in the fact that it's different
however to be completely honest I did
not find it follows very scary in fact I
wasn't really scared by the movie at all
what I loved about this movie was the
cinematography and the way the director
used that cinematography and the
soundtrack to build tension without
using too much gore and that's one of
the best parts of this movie is the fact
that tension generally stays throughout
the whole movie you feel a little
unnerved because of the subject matter
and because some of the things that
characters are seeing those are the best
parts of this movie there's a lot of
hidden metaphors too and images and
photographs that you don't pay attention
to them you're not going to notice
certain parts of the story I love in a
horror movie makes you think and it
actually assumes that you do have a
brain
however there were some aspects of this
movie that did disappoint me mainly
story elements and the fact that I
didn't really scare me because a lot of
critics were like this is the scariest
movie I've ever seen in my life and I
was like no the babadook was definitely
more terrifying that's for sure this
movie is a hundred percent tributing
horror films particularly Halloween
there are entire shots and sequences
that are literally lifted from John
Carpenter's Halloween in fact there's
even a scene where she's in a classroom
listening to a boring lecture if you've
seen Halloween you know where I'm going
with that I'm not gonna spoil it for you
but in my head I said that's what's
going to happen and sure enough it
happened I was like yeah that's maybe a
little too much that's probably copying
off Halloween at this point but all in
all I love the 80s retro tributes
throughout this movie there were just
some certain elements to the story that
I felt attracted from the movie namely
the rules of it and certain things that
have to happen and then certain things
that aren't shown and you're kind of
left wondering which I actually really
like ambiguity in movies but there are
some times when you need little morsels
now this is coming from the guy who
loved enemy and did a 30-minute video
explaining enemy and I love digging deep
into movies and analyzing movies but
there were certain things in this movie
that I would have liked to have known a
little bit more of and there were times
throughout the film where some of the
visual metaphors with things involving
her pool and some things with some
neighborhood kids that were never
explained they just seemed like they
were there to set up random jump scares
at times like a ball hitting a window
really hard for no apparent reason there
are just times when you need a little
bit more meat in a story to be a hundred
percent satisfied I'm not the kind of
person that sits in a movie and expects
to be spoon-fed everything in fact I
hate when movies do that to me that's
disrespecting your audience it follows
respects your audience in a lot of ways
by allowing you to think up things on
your own there were just certain times
in the movie like where she runs into
the woods and sleeps on top of her car
rather than inside her car I'm like this
thing's after you you might want to at
least get in the car roll up the windows
and lock the doors instead of literally
being a sitting duck also there is a 80s
trope throughout most horror films that
came out during that time period where
the parents are just gone they disappear
for no reason and the kids are left to
fend for themselves that happens in this
movie as well the parents just disappear
but at least in movies like Halloween
there was an excuse given where the dad
was like hey I'm going somewhere for a
while by in this movie they're just not
there
and these kids are getting shot at and
stuff like stuff is going down and the
movie is taking itself very seriously so
I expected a little more in the script
to explain why the parents were not
active there I understand that it's a
trope of the 80s but I think that's one
trope that should be left behind if you
want to maintain some more realism
besides a few of those story elements
and a few of those questionable tension
building moments that don't actually
lead to anything I really had a good
time with it follows I love the score
I love the cinematography I love the
performances for the most part makeup
Monroe I believe is how you say her name
she was in the guest another good 80s
retro movie she was great in the movie
some of her friends not so much but she
was excellent and I loved her work in
the film the 80s retro thing is cool I
wouldn't call it unique or original
though like some critics have because
it's something that's already been done
just now you can take that and take the
best parts of it and make it better
which is awesome all in all I'm going to
give it follows a B+ the performances
are great the cinematography is great
the tension is there I just didn't
really find the movie that scary in the
end and there were certain aspects of
the story that I felt could have been
tightened better and a little bit less
Trobe --is-- if you will I'm really
curious to hear your thoughts on this
one because I can tell it's going to
polarize audiences it's not your typical
horror film and that is a good thing
guys as always thank you so much for
watching and please look forward to my
kids on the slope anime television
series review it's going to be up
probably this Sunday I'm looking forward
to bringing that to you guys and as
always thank you so much for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
Oh